étranger
salut bill gates merci beaucoup d'avoir
accepté mon invitation euh donc aujourd'hui
nous allons nous concentrer principalement sur deux
questions euh bien sûr la pandémie parce
que c'est de cela que parle votre dernier livre euh
et aussi le changement climatique parce que c'est
un autre problème principal qui  et c'était aussi
euh le sujet de votre dernier livre juste
avant les règles sont claires pour l'
interview
c'est super on va essayer de l'
essayer euh tout de suite donc
on va commencer
tout de suite quand tu veux  peut simplement
appuyer
et donc la roue s'arrêtera
bien donc c'est un emoji vidéo donc une
vidéo apparaîtra sur l'écran nous la regarderons
d'abord et ensuite nous en reparlerons si
quelque chose tue plus de 10 millions de personnes
dans les prochains  des décennies,
il est plus probable qu'il s'agisse d'un
virus hautement infectieux plutôt que d'une guerre,
pas de missiles, mais de microbes, nous avons en fait
très peu investi dans un système pour arrêter
une épidémie, donc vous savez que cette vidéo est
un extrait de votre ted talk de 2015 il
y a sept ans et ainsi de suite  cette étape ce jour vous  averti
qu'un virus comme la grippe espagnole de 1918
se propagerait très rapidement et vous avez averti
à quel point le monde n'était pas préparé à
faire face à une telle pandémie, ce qui vous a amené
à faire ces hypothèses cinq ans
avant que kovid
bien la fondation gates travaille dans
les maladies infectieuses et donc nous  voir des
épidémies tout le temps
ce qui est très dangereux, c'est euh
le virus respiratoire humain se propage
parce que vous êtes encore en assez bonne santé
vous êtes dans un bus dans un avion et donc à
cause de tous ces voyages,
cela peut devenir mondial vous savez que nous discutons toujours
quand un autre  1918 comme une pandémie est
arrivée
parce que nous voyageons plus, nous
envahissons davantage la nature et vous savez malheureusement,
euh,
la prédiction n'a pas conduit
à des investissements,
j'aurais aimé me tromper
et aucune pandémie n'est venue parce que cela a
été une tragédie incroyable alors  en termes
de solutions pour prévenir une autre pandémie,
c'est ce dont vous parlez dans
votre dernier livre euh vous dites dans votre livre
covid pourrait être la dernière pandémie et les
éléments centraux du livre je  s ces
solutions, alors quels sont les principaux éléments qui, selon
vous, pourraient nous empêcher d'une autre
pandémie,
nous aurons toujours des épidémies,
y compris
des maladies respiratoires, vous devez les
voir très tôt
et avoir une équipe mondiale travaillant avec l'
équipe de pays pour
diagnostiquer les personnes
séquençant ce virus
et  donc vous pouvez l'arrêter avant qu'il ne devienne
mondial
donc c'est juste une épidémie et non une
pandémie
et ce qui rend utile d'avoir une
organisation mondiale nouvelle chose pour
un tel problème des choses comme le feu que nous pratiquons à l'
avance vous savez que les gens savent
euh ils font feu  des exercices et ouais
et beaucoup de pompiers à plein temps vous
avez beaucoup de bouches d'incendie
et donc la beauté de l'équipe mondiale est
qu'ils iront dans tous les pays et diront d'accord
faisons
un entraînement euh ils leur donneront une note
et tout le  d'autres pays diront,
allez, vous devez euh participer
parce que nous sommes tous à risque ici
et
une grande partie du risque est dans les pays à faible revenu
, donc l'équipe mondiale
viendra et complétera
euh leur
capa  capacités
pour les aider à écraser à ce
stade très précoce, nous voyons que dans les films une équipe
de qui,
mais la plupart des gens ne savent pas qu'en ce
moment, qui n'est pas financé pour avoir une
équipe dédiée à la pandémie assez grande
comme
ce que je suggère qui est 3  000 personnes
appelées germe
ouais c'est le nom de l'organisation
vous alors pourquoi germe bien nous comprenons que
c'est un peu loufoque c'est l'équipe mondiale
de réponse et de mobilisation contre l'épidémie
et donc celle-ci serait l'
organisation qui serait capable de réagir
si vous voyez le début  d'une pandémie
dans un pays,
cette conférence ted, comme vous le savez, est devenue virale
pendant kovid et les gens ont été surpris
de la façon dont vous aviez anticipé une telle
pandémie et cela a également conduit, comme vous le savez, des personnes que vous connaissez à
vous accuser de toutes sortes
de choses de financement  les vaccins avec votre
fondation et les utiliser pour suivre les
gens en font de l'argent certaines personnes
envisagent même de considérer peut-être que vous avez
inventé vous-même la courbure
qui vous affecte dans votre vie
quotidienne
bien j'espère que je le fais  il n'y a pas trop de
fous qui
viennent vers moi j'ai eu un peu de
ça où une femme criait que
je la suivais d'une
certaine manière ils ont pris le
contraire de la vérité je dépense des milliards
sur les vaccins par le biais de la fondation pour
sauver des millions, vous savez maintenant qu'ils
disent que je gagne de l'argent et que vous
savez peut-être que les vaccins ne sont en fait
pas pour sauver des vies mais pour euh tuer des
gens, donc c'est un peu pervers
de vous faire dire  le contraire
euh
tu sais je l'avertissement le but de l'
avertissement était de le rendre moins mauvais pas
que tu sais je suis quelqu'un qui veut
quelque chose comme ça
donc je ne m'attends pas à ces théories
j'espère qu'elles meurent je me sens mal que
dans certains cas, cela pourrait rendre les gens
réticents
à
prendre le vaccin et le vaccin est l'une
des rares bonnes choses où nous avons sauvé des
millions de vies
euh pour les personnes qui utilisent les
vaccins une fois que nous avons mis ces théories de
côté euh nous entendons souvent comme des critiques  dans
la façon dont les organisations comme le monde
les organisations de santé
sont financées et en 2018 2019, votre
fondation était la deuxième
entité la plus généreuse au monde finançant ce qui est
juste derrière les États-Unis mais bien devant
tout autre pays,
beaucoup pensent que cela vous place dans une
position de pouvoir unique pour vous pousser, vous en savez
certains  des mesures ou des solutions que vous
croyez être les meilleures pour lutter contre ces euh
problèmes seriez-vous d'accord sur ce
point je suis d'accord que euh le gouvernement devrait
financer qui bien mieux qu'eux et
que vous ne pouvez pas compter sur la philanthropie vous
devez vraiment compter sur les gouvernements
notre fondation  n'a pas de vote sur qui
les politiques sont déterminées par ces
pays votent
le fait que euh le monde a besoin de plus d'
argent pour
les moustiquaires contre le paludisme ou l'éradication de la poliomyélite
c'est pourquoi
j'ai pris les ressources que j'ai eu la
chance d'obtenir de microsoft et les
mettre  dans la santé mondiale, y compris le
renforcement de
qui euh vous savez que nous sommes très proches de l'
éradication de la polio
euh et les dollars que nous y donnons, beaucoup
d'entre eux sont utilisés pour cette
éradication de la poliomyélite  ion effort
nous allons passer à la question suivante maintenant donc
nous allons simplement remettre la roue des emojis
et vous pouvez appuyer quand vous voulez
et ça devrait s'arrêter
bien alors maintenant c'est une image emoji donc
nous allons vous montrer une image et demander  vous une
question qui est assez simple, donc vous voyez
trois personnes sur ce euh sur cette
télévision, donc à part être tous
milliardaires, qu'est-ce que ces trois personnes
ont en commun pouvez-vous deviner
ce qu'elles ont en commun,
elles ont des projets similaires pouvez-
vous croire quel
projet
ces trois
euh sont tous très fascinés par les
voyages spatiaux exactement donc ils ont tous
massivement
investi dans des projets spatiaux donc elon musk
bien sûr avec le spacex jeff bezos
avec un tourisme spatial entre autres
il parait qu'il y a une sorte de
course à l'espace milliardaire dans le dernier  quelques
années,
pourquoi ne participez-vous pas à cette phase
aujourd'hui,
vous savez que je ne suis pas impliqué dans ce que vous
savez, ce qui m'excite, c'est de
se débarrasser de la rougeole se débarrasser du
paludisme, vous savez, faites en sorte que
tout le c  les enfants du monde ont la
même chance de survivre et même de
se nourrir,
donc j'aime la santé mondiale, c'est mon travail à
plein temps, vous savez que nous faisons
des progrès,
je ne vais pas dépenser d'argent pour des fusées
et comprenez-vous que cela peut  être
vous savez perçu comme des milliardaires
s'amusant à essayer d'aller dans l'espace euh alors que
des problèmes environnementaux cruciaux doivent
encore être résolus sur terre
ouais je veux dire
en plus de leur travail spatial vous savez
qu'elon a fait euh des voitures vous savez euh jeff
donne de l'argent au changement climatique  donc
bien que je ne comprenne pas la
pièce spatiale, je pense euh qu'il y a du bon
travail dans lequel chacun de ces trois est
impliqué et concernant euh
les problèmes environnementaux et cette course à l'espace
euh nous avons entendu par exemple jeff bezos um
vouloir déménager  toutes les
industries polluantes sur d'autres planètes pensez-vous
que ce sont des solutions qui pourraient
aider à lutter contre le changement climatique
je ne pense pas que dans un
laps de temps euh
ça compte ça va arriver donc vous
savez que le monde a un objectif  arriver à zéro
d'ici 2050, ça va être extrêmement
difficile euh beaucoup d'innovation beaucoup
de financement beaucoup de soutien politique
mais
malheureusement les planètes artificielles ne seront
pas disponibles pour aider
concernant notre génération donc c'est votre
dernier livre comment  empêcher la prochaine
pandémie, le livre juste avant que vous ne le
publiiez était de savoir comment éviter une
catastrophe climatique, en gros,
ce n'est pas la chose la plus joyeuse dont nous
ayons à parler et
beaucoup de gens, en particulier les jeunes,
s'inquiètent de la tournure que prendra le monde
dans le prochain  des années
ont-ils raison d'être
aussi pessimistes
et j'espère qu'ils sont engagés
à faire du climat une priorité euh
changer la façon dont nous transportons l'
électricité la façon dont nous fabriquons la
façon dont nous faisons les bâtiments le ciment l'acier
c'est un projet incroyable l'
ensemble de l'économie physique  et
euh
l'engagement de la jeunesse en europe je
pense que c'est
essentiel au succès de ça c'est de l'
inscrire à l'ordre du jour c'est d'avoir
les
budgets de recherche le carbo  n idées fiscales
sont là euh l'europe est en quelque sorte en
tête et euh
vous savez les jeunes je pense que dans
presque tous les partis politiques
s'assurent que leur voix est entendue afin que nous
puissions passer à la question suivante donc je vais juste
mettre le volant
encore une fois
la roue des emojis et tu peux t'arrêter
quand tu veux
parfait
alors euh avec cet emoji c'est quelque chose que
tous les candidats à l'
élection présidentielle française ont fait en gros c'est
une série de questions en une minute et
l'idée c'est de répondre oui ou non au
maximum  de ces questions en une minute
et l'idée est de mieux vous connaître
sur votre vision du monde d'
aujourd'hui
êtes-vous prêt pour celles-ci cette minute
peut-être allons-y nous essaierons de
vous avoir déjà triché lors d'un examen
il
y a longtemps sont  tu as peur de la mort
je suppose que je ne suis pas enthousiaste à ce sujet
alors oui tu es ami avec elon musk
euh je l'aime bien je pense qu'elle fait du bon
travail je ne le connais pas très bien commandez
-vous sur amazon
j'achète beaucoup de  livres sur amazon do you
beli  veille tu as plus de pouvoir que joe
biden aujourd'hui
non tu regrettes d'avoir quitté harvard
et non tu crois que la méritocratie existe
aujourd'hui
dans une
certaine mesure d'accord tu crois qu'emmanuel
macron est un bon président pour lutter contre le
changement climatique je fais
était barack obama un bon président
euh  il était bon à bien des égards euh vous
savez j'aimerais que chaque président soit aussi
bon que lui est-ce que l'argent fait le bonheur
euh eh bien un manque extrême d'argent
euh est très difficile
il n'y a pas de corrélation pure entre l'
argent et le bonheur passons au
suivant  question maintenant donc nous allons remettre le
volant vous pouvez appuyer quand vous voulez
donc c'est un emoji de téléphone donc
découvrons en gros ce qu'il y a euh
ce qu'il y a derrière donc c'est une
discussion par SMS entre vous et elon musc donc
le propriétaire de tesla et récemment euh
twitter  les captures d'écran ont été liées
sur twitter et elon musc il y a quelques
jours, comme vous le savez,
cette discussion a eu lieu, donc dans
ce chat, elon musc a dit qu'il ne pouvait pas
travailler avec vous sur la finance  Je choisis des projets
parce que vous vendiez à découvert sur tesla en
essayant essentiellement de faire du profit avec un
plein cours de l'action de tesla et elon
musk voit cela comme contradictoire avec le
désir de lutter contre le changement climatique car vous
dites que vous devriez d'abord soutenir tesla en tant que
développement électrique
pensez-vous qu'il a raison et
surtout comment gérez-vous le fait
qu'en tant que milliardaire, vous pourriez vouloir vous
battre pour des causes quelles qu'elles soient comme le
changement climatique, mais en même temps, vous
voudrez peut-être faire fructifier votre argent
grâce à des investissements
bien tesla n'est pas
à court de capital et tesla a fait un
travail fantastique les voitures sont super
euh
j'ai donné beaucoup plus d'argent au
changement climatique qu'euh elon ou ou n'importe qui d'autre euh
je
donne beaucoup de dollars philanthropiques
je soutiens les entreprises vous savez les voitures électriques
sont environ 16 de  émissions donc nous
devons également résoudre cet
autre 84% euh
mais vous savez qu'il a fait un excellent travail mais
quelqu'un vend à découvert son stock ne le
ralentit pas ou ne le blesse en aucune
façon  euh probablement la dernière question sur
le changement climatique car c'est l'un des
principaux problèmes que nous avons aujourd'hui ou le
principal problème euh nous essayons tous de limiter vous
savez bien sûr notre impact environnemental
dans notre vie quotidienne et au cours des
dernières années, quelque chose a émergé  du moins en
france je ne sais pas si c'est pareil
partout dans le monde c'est ce qu'ils appellent le
flight shaming c'est comme avoir honte
de réserver un vol car vous savez nous
sommes conscients de l'impact que cela pourrait
avoir sur l'environnement sur  l'
environnement aujourd'hui
partagez-vous parfois une telle honte dans
certaines de vos habitudes de vie et
bien deux choses à ce sujet d'abord euh
nous devons innover pour que lorsque vous prenez des
vols il n'y ait pas d'émissions euh
et il existe des technologies pour y
parvenir je ne pense pas que vous  Je sais que le monde
va arrêter de voler, alors multiplier par zéro
est la solution là-bas euh je dépense plus de
neuf millions par an à faire de véritables
compensations de carbone pour que les gens aiment les travaux d'escalade ou en
fait la séquestration euh séquestrer
e  au carbone et c'est donc plus que
mes missions, mon profil d'émissions est très
élevé, je plaide coupable à cela et c'est
pourquoi j'ai mis ce gros investissement à la fois en le
compensant et en finançant ensuite les
innovations afin que nous puissions vous faire connaître les
vols qui n'ont pas euh d'
impact environnemental  merci beaucoup encore merci
d'être là alors je vais juste vous montrer à
nouveau le nom du livre euh comme
c'est bien en français
moi si les gens veulent en savoir plus sur tout
ça merci beaucoup super merci c'est
bon de parler  vous merci d'être
ici bravo pour l'interview première
question bill gates
étranger